[Music]
here we are on the set of Our National
Treasure TV series tell me where does
this all fit in to the National Treasure
University
what
our national treasure series is an
extension of the original movies uh my
character Jess is similar sense of Ben's
you know fantastically brilliant mind I
have an idea where to start so here we
are in the airport in Mexico in our
world and I'm at the concession the
concession stand here and I just found
these rather fabulous
glasses why I like them because they go
with my newly blonde hair
so that just goes to prove plants to
help sporting a blonde blunt wig
Catherine plays Billy a treasure hunter
who lives by her own code she's racing
against Jess played by Lisette Oliveira
to discover a Pan-American treasure
Catherine so we are shooting here in the
lovely Baton Rouge Louisiana what is the
highlight of shooting this show on this
location and have you had any cast
centers with anyone yet well they work
us so hard we barely eat as you know
um well first of all I um I actually
always like
to be on location and you know the hard
part is you're away from your own bed
and you're away from your husband or
your family my husband's shooting anyway
but your kids and your dog and the
Creature Comforts that you like but
what's wonderful about being on location
on this particular series and actually
on anything from me personally is that
you become kind of sequestered within
the world and you
you're just in it you're not like going
home and you know and just kind of
deciding to paint your bathroom the next
day you know so you're sequestered in
the world in which you're playing in
which is great and so down here in Baton
Rouge we've been pretty much working in
Crazy locations which are which are fun
um but I think the one of the best
things for me personally is having the
time to meet you know this wonderful
young cast that that we have on the show
I'm helmed by this gorgeous lady inside
and out
um I've been writing love letters for
her forever no I mean it I'd say nothing
if I didn't think it but I genuinely
think you're just really special as a
young actress and as a young woman with
great morals and great work ethic I've
seen how hard you've wrote on this and
I've seen you how you work on this and
it you
she got it kids you learn from the best
though well and whatever I can do to
help but you know everything they
thought I knew about my mom my dad is
easy riddle that can only be solved by
finding this treasure we both have this
innate desire to discover the truth
behind the treasure it's not necessarily
just the treasure itself but it is the
emotional attachment that both of our
characters have with the treasure so to
be able to it kind of go neck and neck
with another woman who's you know so
brilliant in the sense that things can
just happen in her in her mind and she
has a different way of thinking than
others
um it's quite unique so obviously
there's some pressure there right well
we I've had so much fun because with
this character I play you know I see so
much of myself in you
um actually I see a lot of myself in the
real world in you but in this particular
character how exactly how you said is
that we're we're we're of the same mind
we of the same passion
our paths go different ways but but
nevertheless there's there is a bit of a
cat and mouse aspect to our relationship
show yes absolutely
someone following us
you guys are still in this with me yes
National Treasure we know has
action yes water has a lot of things it
has a it is a ton of things it has a lot
a lot of things but it does have action
and in my past in my films and I've done
a bit of action myself
um tell me what you've done to prepare
here for this and tell me what's the
most kind of action you've done on this
thus far uh running away from cop chases
you know running away from cop cars
spoiler alert just kidding but it's like
it's very very
um a lot of running
um you know what it's what's funny
though is it's more like a like a fake
run because you gotta catch it on camera
right so I remember getting notes like
well set you're too fast and I was like
can't catch me you know it's like yeah I
had to start kind of making it more like
a like a fast a fast
what is this it's called the it's called
uh uh I look gorgeous in my closet but
I'm not really running yeah it's like a
fake little Liam Neeson once called me
the well gazelle no way yeah okay will
you stop the Welsh gazelle because yeah
it's like slow down I'm not running as
fast as you and I and you're a girl and
I wish I should be running faster slow
down read from camera like you're
running so it's like it's like
everything good job you know what I mean
that girl keep us a very big clue well
your kids fans of films what do they
think they'll be starring in the show
well I'll tell you something my kids my
son just graduated
um when I'm congratulations it's been
the longest party ever congratulations
and my daughter is just starting college
so they were babies when National
Treasure came out so when I was cast
opposite you
um I told them I said look I'm doing
this show and um you wouldn't have seen
it it's a bit before you were only
babies when it came out but it's about
you know how much I love history and
treasures and all that stuff you went
are you doing National Treasure so I
went how do you know about that and they
said are you kidding we love those
movies and all their friends when they
knew that I was cast in the series were
like high five I became the coolest the
coolest mom ever and that's what's so
amazing about us being part of that
National Treasure universe is that it's
bands Generations I remember that coming
out and my kids were babies and now my
kids have been watching it and so they
want to see the next installment they
want to see the next generation of it so
that's what makes me extremely hip and
cool with my kids I'm very excited as a
mother so what's your clue I would love
to love to help out we find the three
boxes we'll find the treasure the 10
episode series National Treasure edge of
History premieres December 14th on
Disney plus Harvey Keitel and Justin
bartha provide links to the original
Nicholas Cage film
[Music]
we know Justin bartha is back but can we
see any other familiar faces or story
lines come up it is wonderful to have
co-stars who were in the original as
always because it brings them first of
all it brings an authenticity to the
peace and for those Die Hard movie
national treasure finds it gives them a
little bit of the carrot to to bring
them in and our writers the webs have
done such a great job of incorporating
such really good well-rounded characters
within this fantasy world what do we
need to do to get Nicholas Cage the
guest star can we brainstorm a plant
well
um
certain things I can't do because I'm
married you know what I mean
you can't no but no um no I think I
think what we should do I think we
should you all to escape all of us guys
get together we should give them a
little teaser of some of the great fun
stuff that we're doing so he wants to be
part of our gang and then we should
literally all tune up at his house in
the middle of the night and throw toilet
paper over his house and then and they
say if you don't come with us now
there's going to be some consequences we
were doing what are one of our scenes in
the show if you don't come with us
there'll be some consequences okay so
you'll be hearing for Miss Mr K Mr Kate
please please
oh come on
[Music]